major developments in the wake of
president Trump's former attorney
Michael Cohen's plea deal federal
prosecutors in New York granting
immunity to National Enquirer publisher
David pecker in exchange for information
about Cohen's hush money payments this
comes as the president is blasting Cohen
for cutting a deal with prosecutors this
whole thing about flipping they call it
I know all about flipping for 30 40
years I've been watching flippers
everything's wonderful and then they get
10 years in jail and they they flip on
whoever the next highest one is or as
high as you can go it almost ought to be
outlawed it's not fair if somebody
defrauded a bank and he's going to get
10 years in jail or 20 years in jail but
if you can say something bad about
Donald Trump and you'll go down to two
years or three years which is the deal
he made the president also taking aim
again at Attorney General Jeff Sessions
who recused himself from the Miller
probe the Dems are very strong in the
Justice Department
I put an attorney general that never
took control of the Justice Department
Jeff Sessions never took control of the
Justice Department and it's a sort of an
incredible thing sessions deciding to
fire back at Trump's latest slam vowing
the Justice Department won't be
improperly influenced by politics
meanwhile Senator Lindsey Graham causing
a stir in the nation's capital by
predicting the end may be near for the
embattled AG I think there will come a
time sooner rather than later where it
will be time to have a new face and a
fresh voice at the Department of Justice
after the election I think there'll be
some serious discussions about a new
attorney Joe replacing him before the
election to me would be a non-starter
but the idea of having a new Attorney
General in the first term of president
Trump's administration I think it's very
likely that's what how you set the cat
amongst the pigeons Jessie what do you
think of all this oh well listen a lot
of people are unhappy with Jeff Sessions
performance he has not done what he was
supposed to do with regards to leaks I
think reality winners the only person he
really prosecuted and there's been a lot
of misconduct at the FBI and the
Department of Justice that I don't
believe he wants to get in the middle of
because he doesn't want to
caught in some sort of obstruction probe
himself he never should have recused he
bowed to the pressure of the swamp he
made a mistake
by forgetting some random meeting for 30
seconds with a Russian ambassador and
then all of a sudden he caved so I
understand Trump's concern there but the
Michael Cohen thing I don't really
believe the president wants to
criminalize flipping it's just his way
of saying he doesn't like it and I
understand what happened I mean Cowan
was looking at almost twenty years in
prison and his wife was in the
crosshairs too because the wife also
signed off on their tax returns and he's
a good father as a family man so he
doesn't want to spend 20 years in jail
if he can spend three by doing what the
prosecutors want and saying that yes mr.
Trump did this because he wanted to help
himself with the election I'll sign
anything and that's how prosecutors
advance in their careers prosecutors
don't sit around and not prosecute
people they prosecute famous people and
that's how they move up and they want a
scalp here and this is just one step on
the way to potentially Donald Trump now
there is nothing wrong with paying a
woman to not say something which could
be personally damaging to you or to your
family if he pays this money out of his
personal piggy bank so she keeps quiet
that is not a legitimate campaign
expenditure and John Edwards face the
exact same thing prosecutors went after
him because some rich folks gave him
$700,000 to cover up his affair and
protect his wife it went to the jury and
the jury said you know what this had
nothing to do with the political camp
political campaign they said everything
to do was trying to save his reputation
in his marriage so the law is actually
on Donald Trump's side on this I don't
see this going anywhere except
politically damaging the president he's
wasting a ton of political capital
dealing with these massive amounts of
investigations and the criminalization
of politics and it really is starting to
take a toll on him and it's just it's
disappointing and it's said well go to a
prosecutor for response thank you and
I've never prosecuted a famous person
who I've had to flip someone on all of
mine a murderer
so prosecutors it's a common tool the
most recent one I can remember was a
getaway driver in a murder case you know
you take the least culpable person and
you flip them because you want to know
what's going on at the time of the crime
having said that you've got to have
corroborating evidence plenty of it
and the jury the difference here is a
jury gets to hear hey you gave this guy
a deal hey this guy this guy had got
this deal and he's not going to prison
at all and so they could hear everything
about it and you flipped him and he was
part of the murder but he didn't
actually commit the murder in the other
case with the president all that it's
going to be is in a potential memo for
impeachment so where's that where's that
where is the where's the credibility of
somebody getting into cross-examine him
it's not and they're taking what Michael
Cohen says is fact if in fact they do do
an impeachment memo they're putting it
in there oh he said this therefore it
must be true and once it's out in the
media it's out there and you know sure
down the road Congress will get a chance
to to jump in on it and and weigh in but
by then it's already taken as fact so
that's what troubles me with how they're
doing this why do you want to weigh in
here
I'd love to so I mean first and foremost
there is no deal
Cohen spoke open court in open court and
said what he said he has no deal with
Muller
he has no deal with the Southern
District of New York's federal
prosecutors he made a plea deal because
he understood and said he was guilty of
having committed these crimes and then
named the president as someone who had
directed him to make these payments and
what we've learned today in terms of
what American media the National
Enquirer has done that he was involved
in an effort to cover up these things
Jesse in advance of the campaign that
these payments were made and cooperation
with a media company to protect the
president they had some interesting
language in there
they said in this was basically in a
tripwire so that they would learn of
anybody who was coming to potentially
embarrass the president and they would
stop it by what do they call it catch
and kill pay and kill or something like
that catch and kill these stories now
this is to me
I mean to hear the president talking
about Cohen in this manner and suggest
the course manna for it's okay but Cohen
is a rat it sounds to me like we're
talking about a mob boss and in The
Godfather or something it's unbelievable
Greg do you want to talk about this or
would you like to hear one more piece of
sound from the president about
impeachment I'd like to talk about
anything you want me to talk about
including that tape okay let's listen to
that and you can comment on any of it
and all of it this is the president
talking about what might happen if they
try to impeach him well you know I guess
it's just something like high crimes and
all I don't I don't know how you can
impeach somebody who's done a great job
I'll tell you what if I ever got
impeached I think the market would crash
I think everybody would be very poor
because without this thinking you would
see you would see numbers that you
wouldn't believe in Reverse numbers in
Reverse well you know what he might not
be wrong about the economy because
impeachment is not going to be helpful
but it also could get better because
then you end up with pence and this is
what I think the right is missing they
have to be drilling it into the left's
heads that okay we'll take pence
because backed by the way you won't lose
you'll get two presidents you'll have
President Pence and you'll also have
Trump as a math is a national folk hero
you think Trump's gonna go away if he's
impeached
he'll know he's gonna be right there
every day he's gonna be on TV every day
you're gonna have him and he's gonna be
bigger than pence it'll be hilarious
actually
now about this the David Packard stuff
okay so it's all about suppressing tales
of romps with a Playboy model and so on
I haven't seen a trail of victims here I
see nothing but consensual adults who
got paid okay you can kill stories I
don't think it that's against the law
and I'm you know I'm like three hundred
and twenty three million people out
there I am NOT a lawyer so a lot of this
stuff goes right over my head but I'll
tell you this I listen to al Dershowitz
and he if you watched my prep Air Force
report last night clearest clearest
analysis if Trump told Cohen to make a
contribution that's legal he's allowed
if Cohen did it himself that's a crime
by Cohen
therefore trunkline Trump is not an
unindicted co-conspirator because if
your lawful and the other person isn't
that's not a crime at worst a failure to
report the contribution I'm doing an
alder shoe it's CliffsNotes is a
misdemeanor at most it's not a high
crime again I'm not a lawyer I think
that I'm so glad that Dershowitz can
explain what the media cannot explain
the media immediately jumps and says oh
there's a broken law as for the as for
sessions all this palace intrigue is
tedious and boring and it only serves to
to tell the American public that we are
living in good times if this is what
we're talking about we have a great
economy we have bigger paychecks we have
low unemployment we have what seems to
be like temporary peace so we're talking
about this palace intrigue and the media
is so frustrated I mean the president
tweets about Jeff Sessions threatened to
fire him I mean it's not just people
well that's Powell that leaks I mean
it's the president actually said it well
that's part of the Trump package he's
not just your president he's your uncle
he's your cab driver he's your bartender
you ask him anything he's got an opinion
I've said it before he's like a six hour
drive to an hour at the beach people
love him and and and that's why people
love him and he has a target on his head
from Muller and anybody who gets in the
way is collateral damage hence the
immunity hence all these plea deals
they're gonna do anything they can to
get to the president wait a second wait
a second what about the truth what about
having the American people understand
what took place he goes after sessions
today what kind of man is this well
Jesse his intent is that the Justice
Department serve his needs not serve the
American people
to me this is kind of great by the way
that's just older it was not the most
independent person of the Justice
because President Obama accepted two
million dollars illegal campaign
contribution at $400,000 fund that was
not treated as a felony if not treated
as an administrative violation as a
matter of dossier that was paid Jesse I
won't even let
somebody has laundered through as you
tell me finish you act one firm and
launder through a law firm was not a
legal campaign contribution by a
corporation oh the quote of the day big
double standard they don't want to admit
let me tell you the quote of the day I
have lots of friends involved in this
flippin thing you know who said that
Donald Trump is if he was a mob boss